[Music]
joe biden's speaking out in rolling
stone magazine
finally that guy's talking
finally he's so quiet it's about time we
heard what he had on his mind in a new
interview just came out joe biden says
he spends four or five hours every day
with president obama
yeah in response obama said hiring that
obama impersonator was the best decision
i've ever made
it just
has no
tough news for the democratic party i
don't know if you heard this but since
president obama took office the
democratic party has lost nine
governorships 56 members of congress and
two senate seats
now in his defense obama said i did
promise change
yeah
anyone here from minnesota
well this will work well uh
there's a viking back there that didn't
raise his hand yeah
he's ashamed minnesota has passed a bill
allowing same-sex marriage
yeah
yeah good thing i think so
as a result the minnesota twins are
changing their name to the minnesota
life partners
picture and a
catcher folks
let's all be friends here
we're together for an hour we gotta get
along
hey get this gang
china announced it will no longer buy
recycled trash from the u.s
yeah
i don't have a joke here i'd just like
to give a round of applause
to whatever genius has been selling
trash to china
[Applause]
i wish i had thought of that
next time i go to throw out a cup i'm
going to sell it to china instead
sesame street ladies and gentlemen
sesame street has just introduced its
first latino cast member in decades
yeah
yeah it's an undocumented blue monster
who will work for half as many cookies
a new study shows that owning a pet
lowers a person's risk of heart disease
yeah
yeah
and eating a pet raises the chance you
just had lunch at ikea
that's a true fact
yeah
o.j simpson was
there's no transition here
we're going right from a guy biting into
a horse to o.j simpson
deal dudes o.j simpson was in court this
week
he doesn't shut up
o.j simpson was in court this week
trying to overturn his conviction on
armed robbery and kidnapping
yeah o.j said i'm tired of everyone
thinking me as a robber and a kidnapper
and forgetting what a great murderer i
am
[Applause]
[Music]
i mentioned china earlier and i want to
bring up china again and for a reason
what
why why are you
why are you pro-china
[Applause]
i can't tell what you are
it's a complete
if you're so proud of being chinese why
have you taped a bush to your face
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh we got a good one tonight
it's all coming together tonight baby